[Music]
dianne fosse gained international fame
saving the last of the national
guerrilla death
was found in her cabin in the african
rainforest brutally murdered
hacked to death
i came here essentially for research i
wanted to know
oh there was to be known about them
[Music]
diane knows their personalities their
habits and is learning how they
communicate
many who knew her saw a darker side and
felt she had become obsessed with saving
the gorillas
it was something i just felt compelled
to do i had to do it
i can't explain it even if the police do
solve her murder
another mystery will remain the mystery
of her life
i always dreamed of perhaps going to
africa someday
i definitely wanted to see scenery i
wanted to see trees
i wanted the excitement
i think you're going to find this
discussion fascinating anybody who
wanted to study
mountain gorillas dianne fossey was the
person you wanted to contact
she was famous you're welcome please
dianne fossey
[Music]
what potentially to go and choose this
particular um area of
animals it was something i just felt
compelled to do i had to do it i can't
explain it very dramatically it was
something i knew
there were animals to be learned about
and there weren't very many gorillas
left in the world there certainly are
very few now
the only place you could go if you
wanted to study guerrillas was karasoki
research center
in rwanda i was probably about four or
five
when i first saw the gorillas at the
museum of natural history in new york
city
i felt like the exhibit was alive
[Music]
and i felt like i was stepping into a
world of nature
and it just fascinated me it just
overwhelmed me with excitement
at that point i realized that i want to
see them someday
and then 30 years later here i was
studying mountain gorillas with diane
[Music]
fosse
it was going to be a dream come true
however my dream come true also became a
nightmare
[Music]
it's so hard for me to talk about the
story
because of the emotional pain
when i went into the room you had tables
knocked over
papers everywhere
there was blood behind her head in her
hair
and the gash going across the face over
her nose
onto her cheek there was hair in her
hand
[Music]
i couldn't believe what i was looking at
i couldn't believe
that she's lying there like that this
woman that always portrayed herself as
being strong and everything
totally helpless and totally gone
there are only 200 mountain gorillas
left in the world
which is why i fight so hard for them
the man who kills the animals today
is the man who kills the people who get
in his way tomorrow
i saw her buddy myself
she had been hacked to death with a
machete you know on her face on her head
her eyes were open
and i kept thinking she's alive but
she was not it was
really it was very difficult
[Music]
her last few moments must have been
really awful
she would not have died immediately i'm
sure she's
experienced a lot of pain
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the clear implication is these are the
men who got into her house
i never heard anything about anyone
trying to record
solid evidence of this trail of
footprints
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
i thought to myself well you know is
that her hair
or is that maybe hair from the person or
persons that attacked her
[Music]
i took hair out of her
right and left hand and put them in
separate envelopes
and i cut hair off her head and put that
in an envelope
so it could be sent to the fbi
and the police didn't see me doing that
a world-renowned naturalist has been
discovered murdered at her home in
africa
friends speculated that diane fossey may
have been murdered by
poachers she had fought for the past 18
years
for the outside world knowing having
read about
diane's struggle against the poachers
well it was obvious it was approaches
what did it
but i don't think the evidence stacks up
i think it was much more planned and
sophisticated than
a thief or a poacher going in
something didn't feel right
everything that could possibly be broken
was broken
like someone was in a rage you know or
someone was looking for something
[Music]
drawers were pulled open things had been
pulled out
it looked like somebody was looking for
something
money was not taken there was a couple
of handguns down there
when you don't take the money when you
don't take the gun
when you take anything visible to me
that's
automatically exclude poachers being the
people
it looks like a setup it looked like it
was done to
just make believe that poachers have
done that
whoever came here that night cut a hole
through this corrugated iron with a
machete like this
called a panga then crawled inside and
slashed her to death
someone cut a small piece
three by three feet
hole in the bedroom
that's gonna make noise so
why wouldn't she flee how did she end up
being
killed right there by her bed
the official story was whoever did that
did it from the outside
and got into the house by doing that
but i think it's probably a lot more
likely that
whoever did it did it from the inside
to make it look like that's how they had
gotten in
it almost seemed like it was staged the
amazing thing about it was there wasn't
a heck of a lot of blood
you know i'm wondering what's going on
here if you got slash the machete you
should be bleeding all over the place
was she killed someplace else and
brought back into the room
from what i saw nothing comes together
into a coherent story
it may have been a killing that was
ordered by someone
[Music]
is
when contemplating the vast expanse of
uninhabited
rugged mountainous lands surrounding me
i consider myself one of the world's
most
fortunate people
[Music]
there are no words to describe the joy
and complete satisfaction one feels
after sitting in their midst for several
hours
in mutual trust and confidence
[Music]
at times the rapport simply overwhelms
me
it is the only place that i belong
high in the hills of rwanda in central
africa diane fosse was buried today
she was buried according to her wishes
among the animals that never harmed her
she was buried eight years to the day
since digit's death
whatever happened to her she didn't
deserve being
brutally killed and stowed away in the
ground
[Music]
it was almost like it was surreal
i will never talk to this woman again i
will never
see her alive again
she was a prominent person and she had
been
murdered in a brutal fashion
the rwandans obviously were embarrassed
that this crime had occurred and
probably worried that it was going to
bring negative publicity
i was now in a situation where i was in
charge of this camp
[Music]
soon after the funeral day or two later
i got someone knocking on my door
looked like he might be police or
military and he said
i'm taking these guys down i hope you
understand
[Music]
[Music]
they took away several of the most
important trackers
to be interrogated
[Music]
it clearly as far as we could tell was
not staff
who killed diane if you've had a job for
nearly 20 years do you kill your boss
and be out of work
i was asked to go and deal with her
belongings
and assess the future of the camp
and i went up to karasoki with the
american consul
the embassy had taken possession of the
property
pending an inventory of her effects
[Music]
for me the most significant thing was
looking through a letter file
i found a letter a carbon copy of a
letter to me
that i'd never received
dear ian
the latest poacher captured is also a
gold smuggler between
zaire and rwanda
i examined his clothing to find a letter
between him and his dealer
setting up appointment places for gold
deliveries
it might have got lost in the post but
it's odd that all the other
carbon copies of letters were letters
that i'd received but this one
was missing
gold smuggling that's serious people
people with money and if their names are
on a piece of paper that's evidence
against them
reading that with ian felt
very much like we were that we were
understanding exactly what had happened
there
at that moment
there was always smuggling going on
through the park that was a well-known
fact
[Music]
diane quite often made it known to
people that she had information on them
so they
better watch their p's and q's the
carbon copy of the letters seemed to me
to be important evidence so i've
photocopied it and gave a copy to the
[Music]
authorities
the day after i got back there was a
knock on the embassy door and the police
were there and they said they would like
the hair samples so i divided them up
so they got half the hair samples and i
kept half the hair samples
we were all suspects anybody any
outsider any foreigner that can connect
with karasuki
so we thought it's all kind of absurd
but
it's not impossible that something bad
could happen
one day i had found a skeleton of
gorilla and i brought the pieces back to
camp and put them on
picture table that was near diane's
house
and so i was examining it
i noticed as i looked up there was
somebody in there
i could see them just kind of a shadow
i got concerned so my first response
feeling i'm responsible for the camp
was to go over to the window and to look
in
and actually uh probably wasn't the
smartest thing to do but i
went into the cabin
area
[Music]
did i do that i turned around there was
a guard coming up
i didn't have boxes i wasn't stealing
anything
the event kind of got out of the hand i
went back to my house
there was a hot head there with a gun
and he started yelling and screaming at
me
and he took a rifle like to aim at me
there was nothing for me to gain by
going into the house
what did i need it's a mistake i made
breaking into the house of the unforesee
stealing some of the dams manuscripts or
something
if it's true and he did that and we have
evidence then
i would be suspicious of wayne
next thing you know i was accused of
murder
i received the letter that i need to go
down to the police station
for a questioning the prosecutor came in
after everybody else was there
he came in and he would pace back and
forth like this and look at me
why didn't you hear all the noise when
she was murdered i was sleeping sound
asleep i was the other side of camp
who would have killed diane fosse who
would have killed diane fossey
i said poachers and he kept turning
around and saying
no you killed her you broke in and you
stole her precious documents
you killed her for her precious
documents what you know
i didn't kill her we were friends
and every once while the guy behind me
would push my shoulder like this
pushing me forward so i've got a
prosecutor here i've got an interpreter
over here and someone behind me
and so i was boxed in
i'm by myself and i'm trapped
he would make an accusation and push
make an accusation
push he kept raising his voice kept
raising his voice
over and over and over again louder and
louder push push
i kept saying i didn't do it i didn't do
this he
pushed this paper towards me with a pen
signed the paper
i didn't kill anybody sign it sign it i
don't want to sign a paper i didn't do
anything
you just need to calm down relax and
sign that paper
and the way he said it it seemed like i
was in a bad situation that if i didn't
do it something else was going to happen
there's nobody else here just me the
prosecutor and these other two gentlemen
there's no witnesses there's nothing
i feared for my life
so i signed it and that was it
and i went back to camp
months go by and everything seemed to go
back to normal
during the murder investigation everyone
who worked at karasuki had been
interrogated but then they were released
with the exception of relicana
he used to be one of the best tracker of
the n4c
he had quit karasuki several times
diane's relationship with her employees
was often
very volatile
she would mistreat people
who displeased her
she'd tell someone summarily or fired
get out of camp
then whatever it was usually would blow
over she'd forget about it and
the next time they were due to come up
for their shift they were allowed to
come back to work
[Music]
she was the kind of boss that everyone
hopes they don't get
relicana was more prideful than others
and sometimes would counter diane with
what she said
he would say okay i'm not taking this
out you know i'm leaving
and then he'd get rehired because he was
great
the day diane died he was not there
[Music]
no kavanaugh
be
[Music]
he left and it was his decision and
that got distorted into no
he wanted to go on working there she
didn't want him she fired him
that made him angry
[Music]
at
our understanding was at that time in
the country
the way illegal acts were investigated
was through interrogation
not through physical evidence
[Music]
the rwandans were out of their
investigative
depth it was escalating
in anxiety as a irritant between us
[Music]
the camp staff said two sets of
footprints
came up to the cabin those were two men
who were in camp that night who were not
supposed to be there
it
[Music]
[Music]
we began to get word in the embassy that
that the investigation was coming to a
conclusion good news
we found the culprits we found the
guilty party
in the case of the diane fosse murder
and it is
wayne mcguire the embassy just said
they're charging me with
the murderer dianne fossey and proof i
have to admit at that point
i kind of went blank the authorities
said wayne
and royal carnet had conspired together
to cook up a murder plot
it doesn't make sense wayne couldn't
speak
french queen rwanda or kisohili relicana
couldn't speak english
the gentleman that was arrested they
never met him my entire life
so i have no clue who he is
the best thing we could do for his
safety and security
was to get him out of the country
all of a sudden the adrenaline started
pumping and my only concern was
how am i going to get out of this
situation
i remember getting on the plane and was
terrified
and i was in first class that's all my
mother could get from me
and i was in there with the world bank
people
and they had a champagne bottle about
four feet high and popping it drinking
champagne
and i'm sitting there terrified like am
i going to get out of here
any time someone would just pull over
arrest me
[Music]
i think he was very lucky
[Music]
the hunt is on this morning for an
american wildlife researcher wayne
mcguire
as the prime suspect in the murder of
naturalist dianne faulkner left the
country last month his whereabouts
unknown
rwandan police have asked international
authorities for help in locating mcguire
i want to respond to the outrageous
charge of the rwandan government
that i murdered dr dianne fossey
i had absolutely nothing to do with
diane's tragic death
she was my friend and one of my mentors
i had everything to lose and nothing to
gain by her death
i am shocked and outraged at these false
allegations
the justice department is free to
question me at any time
the rwandans had solved their problem
they had identified who had killed
the prominent american and the american
embassy had
spirited that person out of the country
and so therefore the rwandans had done
their job
[Music]
wade mcguire didn't strike me as someone
who was hiding a guilty secret
there certainly seemed nothing unusual
about
wayne
when i think about wayne knowing him
wayne killing someone
hmm the question is
why would wayne kill the animals
i want to make this clear i did not kill
[Music]
diane
[Music]
we heard that relicana had died
in prison and the official story
was that he had hung himself in his cell
they said that shows that he was guilty
is
[Music]
[Music]
he was a very nice man he was a great
friend he was a
family man just a man of real integrity
it was convenient to go after him and
kill him
and it was terrible
is
maguire was tried in his absence and
convicted with a rwandan co-worker
who allegedly committed suicide in his
prison cell before the trial
i did attend the trial any reasonable
person would have found that
there was no compelling evidence
whatsoever it was farcical
at the trial no defense lawyer appeared
for maguire
no witnesses were called no physical
evidence was presented
the trial lasted 30 minutes
a judgment was rendered of guilty
as charged and a sentence of death was
handed down for wayne mcguire
i thought it was ridiculous and it was
wrong they had no
real evidence of his guilt
none whatsoever
as a random it makes me feel bad
today if i saw a judgment like this
i'd be shocked i would say the judge is
incompetent beyond belief
those who charged him suggested he
wanted to steal
her research that's the word that popped
up over and over again precious
documents precious documents
you had to be as out of touch as that
government of rwanda
to think that you could kill the most
famous person in a field
take their information and publish it
and become famous yourself
they made the accusation that it was my
hair
the prosecutor explained to cnn strands
of hair found in miss fozzie's hand
were sent to a lab in paris for analysis
the lab confirmed the hairs were those
of a white person other than miss fossey
maguire was the only other white person
in the area on the night of the murder
[Music]
from reading the forensic report
established in paris
it is obvious that they did not take any
samples from when
to compare it with the samples they
found in the hands of the victim
so how can this be uncontestable
i don't know
if the report says she had her own hair
in one hand and somebody else's hair
in the other hand why didn't they test
wayne mcguire's hair
[Music]
it could have been her hair because it
was dark hair
she could have just reached up when she
got hit
and grabbed her own hair which would be
a logical reaction i got back a very
uh non-answer from the fbi
it was inconclusive as to whether or not
the hair
in her hands was the hair on her head
it wouldn't be conclusive proof either
way we know that the crime scene was
contaminated by
lots of people moving about the
americans
said to the rwandans you've got to find
out who did this
and so the rwandans did
the rwandan authorities either were
truly incompetent or they didn't
want to solve the crime
if you didn't have
in my view were not the guilty culprits
i don't think you can draw any
conclusions from the fact that the
footprints went by
wayne's cabin the path that's most
likely to get you to diane's cabin
without being heard
is the one that goes by wayne's cabin
diane's murder is still unsolved
[Music]
i didn't believe the official story
it just seemed the rwandan government
was happy to have wayne out of the
country
and relic on it dead and the case could
be closed
she had almost continuous difficulties
with one or another element of the
rwandan government
she was becoming an obstacle a thorn in
their sides
she knew she had enemies
if the government wanted dianne fosse
out of rwanda
they had the power to just
get her out
i keep going back to the gold smuggling
i think someone in a high position
suspected
or knew that she had something on him
and had her killed they certainly could
have found somebody around who would do
it
diane's letter suggests that she had
uncovered
an illegal gold smuggling ring and that
someone in a position of authority
was implicated in that
i think it's possible that an official
could have had her killed
because she knew things
diane had signed a contract for a movie
of her life the film deal that she was
negotiating um for the book carville is
in the mist
she talked about having evidence that
she was going to disclose to the world
people involved in illegal activities
might be afraid of a global spotlight
being
put on them by a hollywood movie
there were perhaps some very powerful
forces at play
trying to silence diane fosse
[Music]
many people were massacred during the
genocide
other just fled the country
the entire court the ranger caught
was burnt down chances of
getting any documentation anything
related to the trial would is
is almost impossible
whoever is responsible is either walking
free
or has has perished in the wider
bloodshed that rwanda experienced in the
90s
i don't think we'll ever know but i
don't think that diane would have
objected to that as an
ending for the script because she died a
warrior
she would have written that
[Music]
it's a tragedy on all sides diane lost
her life relic kind of lost his
and wayne's life was hugely changed
wayne had to change his career
[Music]
losing my academic career what i dreamed
of since i was five years old
was more severe than being accused of
murder
believe it or not
obviously the rwanda of today is a
different place
and there would be an expectation of a
much more i think
fair and modern judicial process
damage is done you know declare my name
would be nice
but to live for that one simple moment
no that's not worth that's not what i'm
looking for
i'm in a different field now i work in
the field of mental health
helping people to recover i'm able to
help other people
because i've experienced trauma
danny's story was a story of courage
[Music]
the gorillas are thriving the numbers
have
doubled since the time of dan fosse
if diane hadn't come to rwanda to
habitual
to start their behavior they would not
be here today
[Applause]
[Music]
if anybody could say that they'd saved a
species i would think a diane could
she undoubtedly turned the world's
attention towards carrillo's she somehow
got behind
the big bluff bravado and found the real
gorilla
it's that amazing meeting of
another mind that happens to be in a
non-human body
that is the magic and that's what diane
opened up to the world
[Music]
you had to learn how to make gorilla
sounds
they like that
the work that she started the
innovations that she
brought habituating gorillas
getting to know them individually and
starting
what she called active conservation is
still
what we do today
the first gorilla she contacted in 67
the descendants of those animals are
still being
followed and monitored and observed
today
guerrilla tourism went from being a
potential threat to the gorillas
to being an important part of the saving
of the gorillas
before she died diane somewhat
reluctantly
admitted publicly that the way it was
being managed
guerilla tourism was changing things for
good
[Music]
it has taken huge effort from everyone
from the government from the partners
working together to ensure that these
animals are safe
[Music]
gorillas in the mist the feature film
based on the life of diane fossey stars
sigourney weaver
as the legendary wildlife researcher
[Music]
after i played diane and spent so much
time with the mountain gorillas
in rwanda it was impossible for me to go
back to
the way i saw the world before it was
such a gift to me
actually to be inside diane's head
i think it was very frustrating to her
that in the hierarchy
of beings on the planet animals were
below
humans since i think in many ways she
thought they were superior
she felt for a while like the only
person who was
concerned about saving them and that was
probably true to a certain extent
she knew the movie would help and i
think she would be
so delighted and
[Music]
let's not say hopeful but optimistic
about
the guerrillas welfare at this point and
even though
880 still means that the gorillas are
critically
endangered it's a lot better than 280
which it was when she died
it's such a shame that diana hasn't
lived to see mountain gorillas
approaching a thousand
that is a conservation success story
which she would have really enjoyed
i looked up into digit's warm gentle
brown eyes
[Music]
he stood pensively gazing down at me
before
patting my head and plopping down by my
side
i lay my head on digit's lap a position
that provided
welcome warmth
when you realize the value of all life
[Music]
you dwell less on what is past and
concentrate more
on the preservation of the future
[Music]
they're healthy and thriving and that
is diane's legacy
[Music]
diane if you were to come back from the
grave she would
just be so happy
[Music]
she did not die in vain
[Music]
her work is continuing and it's going to
[Music]
continue
[Music]
you